what is a planned forward diet hi my
name is Rafi taherian I'm the associate
vice president of Yale Hospitality let's
talk about this great alternative to
your diet
a plan forward diet is a style of eating
that emphasizes and celebrates minimally
processed plant-based food this diet
consists of fruits vegetables nuts and
seeds legumes whole grain and yes even a
little bit of responsibly produced meat
the idea comes from Mediterranean diets
where animal protein is not at the
center of the dish but is instead used
as a flavor enhancer unlike a vegetarian
or vegan diet it doesn't restrict your
eating a vegetarian diet completely
eliminates meat poultry and fish and a
vegan diet excludes all animal products
or byproducts a plant forward diet
thoughtfully refocuses the meal on
vegetables and fruits without
eliminating animal products a plantful
with diet is better for the planet and
better for you animal-based foods have a
bigger carbon footprint than plant-based
Food Plus eating a plant-forward diet
has been shown to reduce the risk of
heart disease fees and type 2 diabetes I
have three recommendations if you're
following vegan or vegetarian diet good
for you just please don't rely heavily
on super processed meat substitutes
number two is be adventurous when it
comes to food the majority of people on
this planet use fresh herbs spice
fermented food and all sorts of other
cooking techniques to create delicious
healthy and bold flavors try it you
might like it three if you're moving
toward a plant forward diet start with
things that you know you like to eat if
it is not delicious to you you won't be
able to stick with it remember it's
better for you and better for the planet
thank you